so i have a broad question to start with
because i might have seen your comment
on
my clip from my interview with marcia
about confident actors
so i wanted to take that and pose it to
you in a different way i know confidence
top to bottom is near impossible in this
industry but
what would you say is the key to
maintaining even like a little degree of
it to
forge forward with positivity about your
work
oh man it's the hardest thing to do
i i have struggled more with confidence
in my work
than i ever have in my life
i guess part of the key i have taken
great solace
in in working with actors who are
better than me who have been around for
a lot longer than me
and hearing from them that it never gets
easier
i know that sounds dark but something
about knowing that you're not alone in
that experience
gives you the the the confidence to at
least keep going i suppose
well you're definitely surrounding
yourself with some good ones because
marsha is hands down one of my favorites
so
what is something about what marsha does
for you on set
as a scene partner that you wish more
actors brought to set
she's honest in her work her range is
incredible
the way that she can take a breath and
sink in and open her eyes and completely
transform in front of your eyes
is so awe inspiring but marcia stephanie
is also the kind of scene partner and
the kind of friend
who will tell you when something sucks
and there is
nothing more valuable than having people
like that in your corner she will tell
you kindly
but she will tell you to take another
crack at it and i and i
i wish more people were able to kindly
let you know when you should give it
another whack
there's a real art to be able to do that
the right way and it makes me even more
impressed by her work
so from one seat partner to another here
i did want to ask you about working with
a baby so much on this movie
my first question actually is was there
ever a fake baby onset or was it always
a real infant
so rarely i have never been a part of
something
where that that involved children and
babies where we used the fake babies so
little
like it was incredibly ambitious but
julia and i spoke a lot about
particularly julia how important
having the baby present was for this
film
because while we talk so much about this
being a journey that
gene undergoes um it's really a it's a
partnership it's a developing of their
relationship and it's a journey that
they largely undergo together
so being able to see the baby's face and
being able to watch the baby grow
we actually shot primarily in
chronological order
so you literally get to watch this baby
grow up before your eyes
i mean it was extraordinary but holy
[ __ ] was it hard
what is an example of a time on set when
working with a real
infant forced you to adapt or change
something as you were going through a
scene
it happened every single day but the the
biggest example because we were
concerned about what the story
implications of it would be
is that there is this there's a scene
with with jean and cow in the diner
where jean
sort of spills her guts to cow and
finally lets
him in and lets him know who she is and
one of the things she talks about is her
lack of confidence
in her relationship with harry but
mentions that she sings to him
and there was a scene in the film before
that scene
where you saw gene singing terry and you
saw how capable she was and how
close they were before she realizes it
and we felt that that was important for
the audience to get to see it and
understand that even though they can and
everyone else can that gene can't see it
herself
but that day the babies were not having
it we tried over the course of
a couple of different days to get that
scene and
and they just were not into my singing
um
and we ended up cutting the scene
but then and this is another gift of
working with babies
there was a day much later in the film
we were shooting in the cabin
it was a late night the babies were kind
of tired but in a good mood
and we were messing around and i just i
started
humming natural woman and our and our dp
picked up the camera and pointed it at
us
and the baby was i forget which one we
were working with that day probably
justin but the baby was sort of
reaching for me and interacting with me
in a way that we could only have hoped
for then
and somehow later in the film felt even
more powerful
it kept it they kept us on our toes
though for sure what a cool thing to
have had come up like that because
that's such a powerful moment
yeah so also this is a first feature for
you as a producer
and that's a pretty huge accomplishment
even with all of your experience on sets
thus far
is there anything about what it takes to
produce a feature that kind of caught
you off guard or surprised you
the length of time it takes um
which was also by the same token a huge
gift and one of the unexpected pieces of
moving into this role as a producer in
addition to being an actor
but i first read the script in and it
can take much much longer than this but
i first read the skip
script in 2018 and we
were still in the sort of late stages of
script development
developing the relationship with amazon
and and um
and sort of asking them to support this
film and the way that we felt like it
would like it deserved and
and of course given the relationship
that i had with them we knew we we knew
that they would
um but also you know all the all the way
through pre-production all the way
through post-production i had never
been through a full post-production
process on a film before
and it is it's now i understand what
goes on in all that time when as an
actor you're waiting for this movie to
come out going my god what's taking so
long
now i know very intimately uh but it was
also really exciting to be able to spend
especially on the front end of the
project
that much intimate time with the
character and to have that additional
context
for the you know from the script
development process and also to be able
to have
the other producer the writers and the
director
in constant conversation regarding the
project and the role
made me a better actor too all the time
that went into it is well worth it it's
fantastic before they kick me out of
here
i want to ask you about the golden arm
because i'm a big samurai i'm a big sam
rainey fan
i know what happened with the viral clip
but i'm curious from your perspective
with that clip that goes out there
it almost the whole episode overall
almost felt like a little bit of an
in-joke in a very classic sam raimi
style and that clip
goes viral without the ending so do you
feel like it was kind of a situation of
people
i don't know getting the joke but not
getting the punch line
i don't think they got the joke like it
was i think that was the most
frustrating part about it because
you would know as a fan of sam raimi i
mean the huge reason to do this project
i had this meeting with sam raimi having
been familiar with his work from afar
you fall in love with the man instantly
the passion that he has for this
practical horror which is not
necessarily a genre that i would have
been attracted to
is infectious it's so exciting i mean it
and it was like that on set it was one
of the most fun experiences i've ever
had
and you you know you have this
experience of someone like sam raimi
going more blood more blood cannons let
me pour the blood all over you
and and you know you know it's camp it's
it's classic
sam raimi camp and so it was kind of a
bummer for a project that i think very
much
was what it set out to be for this more
serious part of the the the show
to go viral so that people could rip it
out of that context that truthfully
can bring people so much joy
well well while it was short-lived it
did bring me some joy so thank you for
that
huge congratulations on this i can't
wait for everyone to see it